the nominees for Best Performance by an
actress and a leading role in a play
Lauren read laughs children of a lesser
God the first time that I was introduced
to children of a lesser God was when I
was 8 the movie came out and my parents
decided to take me to see the movie even
though they knew it was for adults right
it had a huge impact on me to see
another deaf adult on the big screen I
mean I never once thought that I would
be Sarah first of all I'm a woman of
color and I just assumed that it was a
given that Sarah was going to be white
I was a school teacher so I taught
kindergarten and first grade and public
education every day I had to read aloud
with my students and that always
involves acting in a way and a tough
audience children and then I left to
raise my own two boys Kenny was
presented with the possibility of doing
a revival of children of a lesser God
and he decided that he wanted to meet a
person who was deaf first so he
contacted me we set up a time to meet
and then we set up a plan to meet once a
week for a year and we would talk about
Deaf culture I would teach him some
signs so after a year of meeting and I
was his teacher and he was my student he
then asked me to be a participant in the
first reading with Joshua Jackson and
after that reading was over he pulled me
aside and said if this goes all the way
are you willing to go all the way and my
answer is pretty clear
nope no here no speak no see no hands
and working with Joshua Jackson made the
whole process so easy he's such a
veteran he's been in this industry for
so long I was always expected to learn
to speak but I don't speak I don't do
things that I can't do well this story
holds such a special place for the deaf
community you know it opened doors to
Broadway back when it first was
performed
we definitely have a long way to go
regarding inclusivity in this business
when you hear the word inclusion in this
industry it tends to focus on color and
I think we need to broaden that to
include people with different abilities
as well it makes us better
people once your eyes are opened and you
are exposed to differences different
ways of living different ideas your
feelings grow and once you're exposed to
something like that you can't go back
you can only move forward so I think
it's really important to meet people to
hear their stories especially if their
stories are not like yours because when
you do you find that Universal
connection
[Music]